it is game week for the raiders oh we've
been waiting to say that the first game
with fans at allegiant stadium coming up
saturday night
it won't be the first time however that
fans have watched the raiders inside the
death star
sports director chris matthews joining
us with more on sunday's practice chris
well i knew you'd like that
kirsten yeah game week here we have
fight week now we have game week
i'll tell you what season ticket holders
they were invited to watch the team
inside the stadium this past weekend on
sunday as a matter of fact
it was only practice so it was never
going to be packed with fans who
showed up but they did show up and they
were pretty excited estimated about 15
to 20 thousand showed up to watch this
team and
the team noticed also they enjoyed the
experience
after most of raider nation really has
had a chance to even see this team in
person now for two years
that's why i came back to coach
especially with the raiders it's always
been
you know the best time of my life and to
share it with raider fans again for the
first time in a long time was was
special and i just can only imagine what
it's going to be like when seattle comes
in to start the season it'll be
very loud i would expect for us as
players i think
having the fans around again it just
creates that atmosphere
that we all crave so much and i it was
it was quite enjoyable and i can't wait
to see this thing sold out and packed
and
you know our fans always bring the juice
all right now the raiders preseason
opener saturday with a
6 p.m kickoff it'll be interesting to
see how many of raider nation fans do
show up to attend that game
so far the only games that fans have
really been inside the allegiance team
to watch have been those
unlv football games now